welcome to cloud on air live webinars
from Google cloud we host these webinars
every Tuesday my name is Matt dollar and
today we'll be talking about automated
canary analysis joining me our Steven
Kim from Google
Michael Graff and Chris in and from
Netflix and they'll introduce themselves
as they they come up to speak you can
ask questions any time on the platform
and we have Googlers on standby to
answer your questions so let's get
started we're going to start with a
pretty high-level overview of sea icd
continuous integration and continuous
delivery then we'll dive into exactly
what a canary releases will talk in a
fair amount of detail about Kayenta
itself and how it integrates with
spinnaker then we'll do a demo then
Chris will come back up and he'll talk
about different practical considerations
to keep in mind as you start to employ
automated canary analysis and your own
release pipelines then Stephen will come
up and he's going to go through the
various steps of getting spinnaker
installed just kind of a pathway to
follow install spinnaker enable canta
configure everything what kind of
metrics to look for where to find the
various community members involved and
then we'll do some Q&A so get your
questions in early and we'll tackle as
many as we can at the end of the
presentation so this is a fairly typical
development teams workflow you can see
it's it's rendered as a loop the idea is
that developers are always making
changes they're always pushing changes
the changes are constantly integrated
into the main branch of a shared source
code repository all of those changes are
subjected to automated tests and
ultimately builds are automatically
produced that can be released into
production at will you want to avoid the
scenario where you plan releases over a
period of many months and it's a big
risky operation the idea is to automate
everything from I make a change my
source code I push it you know go
through all the various test Suites
automatically produce a build get it in
a state that it's ready to be deployed
into production at any time with the
push of a button we don't want this to
be a big risky thing it should be boring
and safe and you should be able to do
this at any time keep in mind when we
talk about releases throughout this
presentation we're really talking about
any production change it can be a code
change it can be a change of the
configuration of the application it can
even be changes to the infrastructure
underlying the application itself with
this in mind a primary goal of spinnaker
is to make releases boring safe and
repeatable canary releases are just one
tool in the spinnaker toolbox to make
releases safer
as you hear all of us talk about
Canaries and we're gonna show all the
different configurations and we may hear
and they're described as testing keep
mind it really is not in any way a
replacement for other forms of testing
as you build out your release workflow
for your shop this is not a replacement
for unit testing integration testing
capacity and load testing or any other
form of automated tests it's just an
additional thing that you can employ
with the goal of increasing your
confidence that a new release safe to
the fully deploy into production without
slowing down your development workflow
next up Chris is going to come up and
he's going to describe exactly what a
canary release is
great thank you Matt so to expand on
this idea of a canary Redux further it
is really a deployment pattern or
release process where a new change
whether it's code configuration as Matt
alluded to that's deployed into
production but for a subset of our users
and so it gets us terminology or its
name from the coal mining industry where
miners would take a canary bird into the
coal mine with them and these birds
would act as an early warning signal to
the buildup of toxic gases this would
give the coal miners a sense of safety
as they worked in the mine in a similar
way a canary release can help make a
deployment safer by reducing the impact
that anyone can change any one change
can have on your environment and this is
because the canary as you release it
it's gonna serve a small subset of your
traffic if something catastrophic
happens or goes wrong it will only
impact a small percentage of you users
and so this can lead to safer
deployments by reducing that blast
radius now to emphasize what Matt had
said a canary release is not a form of
testing or is not to replace testing and
of itself it's just another tool towards
a safer deployment and augments or
enhances the CI CD workflow now as part
of a canary release a decision does need
to be made we're going the behavior of
the canary if the behavior of this
canary or our release or a change looks
good then we want to take that and
deploy to the rest of production or to
all of our users to help facilitate this
decision-making we do need to collect
metrics but describe the behavior of the
system now these metrics do need to be
tagged or name-space in a way such that
we can easily retrieve them after the
fact so you can think of this as making
sure that when we report metrics every
report metrics independently for the
canary and for say our production
service so we can visualize or do some
analysis later with them so once we have
a set of metrics that have been
collected a decision is usually made by
looking at graphs and dashboards
manually and trying to decide does the
canary look good and you can kind of
think of this as a game of spot the
differences where you're looking at the
behavior of the canary that's determined
by these set of metrics in relation to
that production system and you're really
trying to determine if the behavior that
can
hurry is significantly different than
the production system then based on that
decision you may decide to deploy that
change or that canary to all your users
or to the rest of your production
environment however this manual process
of looking at graphs and dashboards can
be error-prone
it does require subjective assessment
and is prone to human bias and errors so
I may look at a canary result or the the
results of a canary and decide it looks
good but Matt may come along and based
on his experience you may look at that
and say things are ok let's push to
production so in addition you know this
process of man you looking at graphs and
dashboard is time consuming you know
having someone look at all the graphs or
results just doesn't scale and as you
move towards more frequent and rapid
deployments having someone there to gate
every deployment is is not so feasible
and then finally it can be very
difficult to assess the quality of the
canary in relation to the production's
cluster or the production deployment
you know the canary is not serving the
same amount of traffic or doing the same
type of workload as production and this
makes it very difficult to compare the
canary to production and good get a good
sense of the behavior and to address
these issues we can enhance the canary
release process in primarily two ways
first we can introduce an independent
baseline group or server group as part
of the canary release process and so the
baseline here is going to be running the
same version or configuration as
production so in our diagram here it's
going to be running say version 1 at the
same time we're gonna create the new
canary version as well and this is gonna
be version 2 now the baseline and canary
are gonna both be say one server or one
instance and they're both going to serve
the exact same amount of traffic so for
example if the canary is serving five
percent of our traffic and is one server
our baseline is also going to be one
server and serving five percent of our
traffic now it's important to remember
that these clusters or these server
groups are gonna be serving a very small
percentage of our traffic and again this
is to limit the blast radius that any
type of change can have on our end-users
now once we have this environment set up
we can compare apples to apples we can
now compare the canary directly to the
baseline and make some type of automated
decision
and this is where kyoto comes in it's a
platform for doing automated canary
analysis so michael will now come up and
talk a little bit about kantha and how
it integrates with spinnaker thank you
Chris
hi anta is our open source platform to
allow canary analysis for to add to a
pipeline within spinnaker spinnaker is
our open source deployment platform
built jointly between Netflix and Google
these are all open sourced and we have a
strong community around spinnaker
already and we're intending to build a
strong community around Kayenta
especially around adding new judges and
new metric data sources Spinnaker's role
is to set up the canary such that CAI
anta can perform judgements on that data
for example here we have a baseline
which is running exactly the same
production code or configuration that
the main production or the main
production system is running and the
canary is running the new change it
could be a configuration change or it
could be a code change and client or
spinnaker will call upon Cayenne to one
or more times during a some time window
to perform judgments on how healthy that
canary is in relation to the other how
traffic is actually routed is somewhat
application-specific one common example
which will show later is a load balancer
which was simply however many instances
are available each one gets a certain
percentage of traffic but in some
situations you may have to choose a more
complicated proach where you send of one
percent or some small amount of traffic
to your canary and baseline the pipeline
this is a simplified version of a
pipeline in this case we have spinnaker
deploying the canary and the baseline
and then call me upon clients a one or
more times to get the individual scores
in this example we have three scores in
this case 90 92 and 95 those could be in
different regions different locations
New York and California they could also
be across multiple time windows a very
common scenario is to deploy for a
four-hour canary and have 30 minute
intervals so we weight a small period to
let things warm up and then every 30
minutes after that we perform a canary
analysis based upon the result of that
score we will
a spinnaker Oh decide whether not I
should continue deployment to predict
production or roll that back and cancel
the canary operation wen-chi anta is
actually performing that each analysis
this is the following the steps it takes
it will gather the metrics for both the
baseline in the canary for each metric
that's defined the configuration file
that's why it's important that we can
separate those out and they have to be
tagged properly so we know is this a
canary metric or is this a baseline or
production metric well validate that we
got the data that we expected align the
data together so that the similar
metrics from baseline and canary align
up
will then perform some cleaning make
certain the data is easy - easy to
compare compare each individual metric
as either a pass a fail and a fail can
be either high or low and you can
override which direction you're
sensitive to so you can choose high as
okay low as okay and finally an
individual score is computed and this
individual score is a snapshot in time
this is what the canary looked like at
this moment when you do a four-hour
window you in multiple Canaries you
expect each one to pass and there's a
lower threshold at which will cancel and
an upper threshold at the end at which
will accept so here to give a demo is
Matt thanks Michael we'll just have to
navigate to the other tabs to do the
demo we're going to do a live demo so
fingers crossed
all right so just to give an idea of
what you're gonna see we're gonna start
with a quick high-level overview of
spinnaker we assume some viewers
potentially haven't interacted with the
spinnaker user interface before may not
be very familiar with it so we'll
introduce some of the more important
topics and then we'll work through the
full process from beginning to end of
defining a canary configuration figuring
out which metrics to you is how to apply
this to a set of release pipelines we'll
walk through the configuration of those
pipelines and then we'll we'll kick
everything off by pushing some changes
which we'll show in detail and then
interact with results poke around the
reports and so on
so what we're viewing now is the
clusters view think of this as the
operational pain or operational view of
spinnaker it shows all of the various
resources we have under management in
this case we're managing things deployed
to Cooper Nettie's so represented on the
screen now or for individual
mints spread across two namespaces of
production and a staging namespace and
this is a sample application just for
the purposes of this demo there's a
front-end component a back-end component
and they constitute a very simple web
application they're details of it it's
written and go but they're not they're
not that significant but the important
thing to keep in mind here there are
four deployments they're already running
some in production some in staging it's
a pair of front-end back-end in each so
one thing to note as we look here I've
highlighted this deployment you can see
the details and the view on the right
hand side and you can see each of these
little individual green Chiclets these
represent pods and this is the most
important thing to note at the moment
where it says V 14 this is associated
with the 14th provision of that
deployment within kubernetes we have the
revision history set to zero so you
won't see the older ones as they're
scaled down to zero they'll be destroyed
but there it is to keep in mind that
revision because as we work through the
release process you'll see that revision
is going to roll forward and 15 motional
okay so this is the automation via the
operational view the pipeline
configuration is the automation view
which we're going to come to in a moment
and remember our goal here is we're
going to configure an experiment with
pre-configured pipelines that use the
automated canary analysis service
so before we configure the automated
canary analysis stage within any
pipelines we need to have some canary
configurations available so that's the
next view that we're going to experiment
with so I believe Chris touched on this
or will in a moment one of the ideas is
to co-locate the configurations for the
the automated canary analysis runs with
the applications themselves this is you
know this is tweakable you can have it
so that your canary configurations can
be used across all applications or are
scoped to a set of applications but the
primary goal is that the operators of
these systems want to have their canary
configurations close by to the services
and applications that they're using
those canary analysis configurations
with so there's a full user interface
with capabilities for editing these
things and managing them over time
they're all persisted along with the
other artifacts of spinnaker so in this
case we're deploying kubernetes and
we're using stack driver to monitor
those those resources it's I would
considered a you know prerequisite of
using any of this that all of your
systems are properly instrumented so if
you're not implementing your application
in your infrastructure there's no way
you'll be able to select appropriate
metrics later on for use in the canary
analysis in this case we selected three
very simple metrics you can see them
down below we'll just show the
configuration of one of them so we're
looking at the CPU request utilization
for containers again it's on kubernetes
we give it a name we're using this thing
we call custom filter template and the
idea here is that you can use some of
the out of the out of the box
capabilities for building the queries or
you can customize it any way you like it
really depends on your use case the most
important thing touches on something
that Michael said which is that you must
know in order to use this system how to
segment your data if you can't clearly
identify which data was collected or
which metrics were collected from your
baseline and which metrics were
collected from your canary you won't be
able to run the analysis and compare the
aggregated results of each so we have
this canary configuration it has a name
and now we're going to go over the
pipeline view and we're going to
interact with thee the pipeline
configuration and select this canary
config for use as part of a rollout okay
so this is a fairly typical setup there
are three pipelines first one is
deployed of staging then we have
deployed with automated canary analysis
and then promote canary to production
the goal the first pipeline is to be
triggered when any whenever any push
that's relevant to this deployment is
picked up so that could be a change to
one of the underlying containers that
could be a change to a manifest in this
particular case we've configured this
pipeline to kick off whenever front-end
or back-end container images are changed
or when either of the manifests
associated with those deployments are
changed we won't go step by step through
the configuration but it's important to
know that's how its kicked off because
we're going to push a change and it
makes sense to know where that's coming
from so if we look deeper into the
pipeline
we then see two parallel deployments
it's gonna deploy front end and back end
but each of them are going to staging at
this point we're not doing any canary
their goal here is to show how we
integrate a canary release into this
process so we deploy front end and back
into staging we run some simple
acceptance tests over the back end which
in this case really amounts to a
kubernetes job running a curl command
against the internal back-end service
and whichever namespace it's in which in
this case will be
staging and lastly a manual judgment and
all that manual judgment is forced in
this case a human to say I'm happy with
how it worked out in staging I'm ready
to promote it into production so I'm
gonna kick this off and then we'll come
back and look at the other
configurations so what we've done here
is make a very simple change to the
manifest that backs the back end
deployment we've dramatically restricted
the resource allocation for CPU for the
back end so that when we collect the
metrics for CPU utilization it should go
up quite a bit from baseline to canary
so it has one twentieth of the
allocation of the baseline so we'll push
this change and all of all this change
is doing really this operation it's just
pushing that updated manifest to a
storage bucket in this case it's GCS and
this pipeline is configured to listen
for pub/sub events so we see it it
already kicked off an instance of that
that workflow we would expect the front
end to complete quite quickly kubernetes
is smart enough to detect if it's really
an OAuth push which in this case we
didn't change the front end it'll
complete quicker than the back end right
so the back end will take a moment it is
updating that manifest so we should see
this obviously that revision should roll
forward and there's the new 115 and then
you'll see 14 will slowly go away over
time if we had left the revision history
set to anything higher than zero for
that deployment you would see the old
revision would remain even though it
would have zero pods in this case it
will go away over time so we let that
carry on with its work we'll go back to
the pipeline's view it's deploying it'll
take a moment and what's gonna happen
next I'll show you the configuration
while we wait actually going pretty
quickly so we the next pipeline is
deploy with automated canary analysis
this pipeline is not configured to
listen for changes to the manifests or
the container images its configuration
just has it listening for a pipeline to
complete successfully and it's that
deployed a staging pipeline and will
inherit all of the artifact information
so it'll know what images were deployed
it'll know what manifests were deployed
and it can use all that information in
its execution but it's not listening for
changes to them it only waits for that
parent pipeline to complete and then
what it does is again we see this
parallel deploy scheme it's going to
again deploy those images and manifest
that are under test
run in and back-end only in this case
instead of deploying the staging it's
going to deploy into production then
it's going to run the canary analysis so
let's just-okay this manual judgment and
then we will carry on looking at that
configuration so we'll give that a
moment while that's thinking let's look
at our cluster setup so remember for the
next step that each of the existing
deployments have five pods because as
Chris and Michael both touched on when
you do your canary you want to do with a
smaller percentage of traffic this is a
demo it's dramatically simplified we're
not deploying another baseline we're
actually comparing the canary to the
existing baseline which is not ideal you
want to restrict the amount of traffic
that canary takes so in this case well
we have five existing pods we're going
to end up deploying Canaries that have
one pot each it's going to end up taking
one-sixth of the traffic which is which
is a bit but it's it's it's a demo so
let's look at the configuration it's
doing the deployments now but let's look
at this canary analysis stage so it's
pretty straightforward there are not an
enormous amount of configuration options
here at the moment but the most
important setting is right at the top
and it lets you choose either real-time
or retrospective if this were not a demo
and we weren't doing this cooking show
style we would do real-time the
deployments would happen and then we
would wait we would give it a warmup
period we would wait let's say you know
20 minutes and then maybe do 4 Canaries
over the course of two hours in each one
would be a 30 minute canary analysis run
so that would be real time but we're
doing retrospective because we don't
want to wait most of the settings are
the same except instead of waiting and
then breaking it into pieces you encode
the timestamps directly within the
canary stage configuration so we're
using some time stamps from data we
collected earlier in the day other than
that it looks exactly as the real-time
setup would so you see here we've
location for baseline and canary we just
give the name space for each of those
and then you have baseline and canary
scope so the baseline well we just want
the primary this is as we said it's just
the baseline deployment for the back end
component for canary we want back end
canary in the case of this configuration
this is how we're segmenting the data
we're using a naming scheme and some
labels and things like that this depends
on your use case there are lots of
different ways to do this especially
with kubernetes the most common case is
just to assign labels that let you
identify
where the metrics were collected from so
it's really use case dependent this is
just one path we say what it is we're
examining their kubernetes containers
then we get down to these scoring
thresholds I don't think we touched on
these with the canary configuration but
as you you you decide which metrics you
want to query as part of your canary
configuration you can group them
together and then assign weights to
those groups and all of that is built up
into a resulting confidence score for a
given canary analysis run but as a given
run can contain multiple intervals we
allow you to specify this threshold
called marginal and where this is used
is that as each interval run is
completed if the confidence score is
below the marginal threshold it just
pulls a plug it says pull the ripcord
we're gonna punch out now we're not
going to do the future runs don't pay
the cost so long as all those interval
runs are above the marginal threshold it
will carry on and do all the future
intervals where the past threshold is
used is for the final confidence score
so the score returned from the final
interval of the canary analysis runs as
long as it's above past that canary
stage is considered a success if it's
below it's considered a failure as with
all spinnaker stages there are a host of
configuration options about what to do
in the case of a failure do a halt all
pipeline just this branch do you ignore
it and so on so it's highly configurable
all right so in this case it's hard to
read I know but we have a one hour
duration between start time and end time
and we set the interval to 30 minutes so
it's going to result in two canary
analysis runs and we set the look-back
type to growing and what this means is
that you'll see a run with 30 minutes of
data and then a run with 60 minutes of
data you could do sliding as an
alternative as we get into this and
we'll talk more about this in a moment
but the goal of retrospective analysis
while it's sweet to use for demos the
real goal is to allow you later on to do
further experimentation refine your
canary analysis setup and experiment
with different types of judging
different metrics stores different
Precision's where the metrics you're
collecting and so on so if we go back to
our view well it did the deployment here
so remember we said here yep we're happy
we want to deploy the canary to
production it does the deployment of the
front end to production the back end and
then it does the canary analysis runs
and then you see it did the two runs so
you can see duration is thirty minutes
duration is one hour it'll show you the
timestamps here and there's a sniff D
copy to clipboard thing if you want to
do a retrospective analysis using those
values but really what we want to get to
is the report so if we click on this
report and all these you eyes are brand
new it's something we're really proud of
dan peach on our team here at Google
worked with a fellow named Scott from
from Netflix to build out all these you
eyes from scratch including the
configuration the reporting all of it
it's it's really great we're pretty
pretty pleased with it so you can see
her these are the three metrics we
configured in that canary config we
looked at earlier and one of them is hi
the other two are pass we didn't do
anything fancy with the weights so you
can see just based on that confidence
score obviously it's two thirds because
two past and one failed and they're
equally weighted
by default but here you can see blue is
canary baseline is this other color
which i think is copper I'm not sure
what color that is
but you can see the CPU ization for that
given metric was obviously much higher
because we we really constrained the
resource allocation for CPU of that
deployment so what we've seen here
besides the quick kind of 15-second
blast of this is spinnaker is what the
clusters look like which are deployments
because we're on kubernetes here how to
navigate the operational view of
spinnaker how to configure your
pipelines to use the canary
configurations that you can curate
directly within the user interface then
we pushed a change which was a modified
manifest we put to a GCS bucket pub/sub
event trigger that first pipeline did
the deployments it did the simple test
we said yep we're okay push the Canaries
into production it pushed the Canaries
around the analysis if you look at what
was pushed this is pretty cool in that
if you look at well look at the
production environment for back-end
there are five pods and then if you look
at back in canary there's one pod that's
how it's getting that that small amount
of traffic and lastly before I turn it
back over to Chris there is another
pipeline here that's configured to run
on successful completion of deploy with
automated canary analysis and this is
really the promotion pipeline if this
runs all it really does is provision the
new deployments scale them up to full
capacity and destroy all the Canaries
and do some cleanup one last thing that
canary analysis stage we showed is quite
simple and right now focuses exclusively
on configuring
analysis runs but we're in the process
of building out full provisioning
capabilities within the stage itself so
you can't employ the best practice that
Michael and Chris described where as
part of your canary analysis you
provision a new baseline a new canary
and you compare apples to apples and
then do all the cleanup afterwards and
there are all sorts of options
associated with that so that's in
progress now you've seen how is this
next up is Chris and he's going to give
you some things to keep mind practical
considerations as you deploy this in
your own environment
great thank you very much Matt so we
have been using automated canary
analysis and Netflix for well over four
years and realizing the benefits of this
style of deployment and over these years
we have learned many lessons about
canary analysis and a few of those we
hope to share with you here today
now something I do want to emphasize is
that canary analysis is a very iterative
process that does need to be refined
over time per say each of your
applications as your applications evolve
you make changes you add new features
your canary release process and your
configuration that goes along with it is
also going to change and evolve as well
so for example let's say that you're
going to be using some new hardware or
some new infrastructure for your
application this may also change the
metrics or the way that you perform a
canary and this is going to need to be
iterated iterated on as well now this is
particularly true about the metrics
which are used to assess or judge the
canary as well and so by you know we
want to select metrics that describe the
behavior of the system the system and
this is important for the success of
automated canary analysis now the power
of automated canary analysis comes from
one the set up of the infrastructure so
creating that baseline of canary groups
but also comes from those metrics and
how we analyze them and so picking those
metrics will take time to get right but
is a very important stepping a step to
realizing the benefit of this approach
in gaining trust in your deployments and
so for example if your canary is always
showing differences as compared to your
production cluster based on some set of
metrics you selected you may lose trust
in the system over time and it may lead
to more time for you to investigate and
will reduce your deployment cadence and
velocity therefore you will need to
refine these metrics over time and to
make them very important to your
application and to your release process
in general and this is why as part of
our work with cai anta we did integrate
the metric configuration and the canary
configuration right into spinnaker
alongside with your applications and
matt had showed a little bit of this in
his demo our goal was to make it as easy
as possible to find update and manage
was types of canary configurations and
metrics definition for example in the
screenshot we see here we have a set of
metrics which we are defining and
they're in Si one group called group one
here we want to make these reside
alongside the application in this case
it's just an example called my app but
we can see I have multiple canary
configurations here example config and
test and we want to put these right
along with the application to make them
easier to find but also to allow people
to come in and modify it and update them
along with their rest of their
continuous integration or continuous
delivery pipelines now there are a few
best practices that you can follow when
trying to select these metrics for
automated canary analysis and so for
example sparse metrics which rarely
report any type of signals are not real
good candidates for canary analysis and
this is because of the low reporting
interval of these metrics will be a
little hard to analyze now in contrast
to this you know certain types of error
metrics make good candidate signals as
they are very clear indicators of
failure I know these metrics can be very
easy to analyze and reason about for
example if you're looking at an increase
in error rates for an HTTP server then
it is you know a very clear indication
of failure if your canary has a higher
rate of these types of errors and we can
see that in the graph on the right here
and finally metrics which relate to
application configuration may not be a
good signal for canary analysis for
example let's say you're looking at the
max number of configured threads free
application this is not necessarily
going to be a good indicator of failure
as in the face of a failure the canary
baseline will most likely show the same
result and so these aren't contributing
anything to your canary analysis and
will want to be removed or tweaked for
your analysis now in addition to picking
the right metrics which is very
important there are also some other
practical considerations to keep in mind
or think about as you employ canary
analysis and for example when an
application does startup it may throw
more errors or have higher utilization
and this can be because of caches
failing getting warm
it can also because of garbage
collection or the application
establishing connections to say down
streams or up streams now these types of
start with
will skew the results of canary analysis
and for this reason you'll want to
ignore these types of start-up effects
as part of your canary release and so
within spinnaker and within KY Anza we
allow you to configure a warmup period
and for example we can see that we're in
this example setting a warm-up period of
10 minutes in this example we're gonna
ignore the first 10 minutes of the
metrics and then perform the analysis
this will give you a little bit better
confidence in your data and into the
canary release process and finally
you'll want to consider how big to make
your canary deployment or how much
traffic your canary release is going to
take so in this example we have here our
canary deployment is going to be taking
25% of our traffic this example is the
traffic is routed based on a load
balancer so this means that 25% of our
traffic is at risk of this new change or
this canary we are releasing now this is
contrary to the idea that a canary is
about reducing risk and so there are
some balances or trade-offs you'll have
to make in terms of how big to make the
canary or how small to make the canary
and so in this example here we may want
to use a smaller number of servers maybe
we use only one server for the canary or
find a different way for our traffic to
make its way to the canary you can also
you know debate should we even use a
canary in this case let's say that my
application is one instance or one
server a canary it may not be the right
tool to use in this case to mitigate
that risk of a change so up next steam
is going to talk a little bit how you
can get started with spinnaker and
Caliente
hi I'll point you in a couple of
directions by which you can get started
on your journey to doing canary analysis
based rollouts on your project or in
your organization's first you need to
install spinnaker down below on the
screen there's a spinnaker dot IO our
website slash setup there are a number
of ways that you can go to install
spinnaker on various different platforms
and different configurations and there
you can get all the information you need
to get Senate crisp inner core installed
for those of you who have already
installed spinnaker and are running
spinnaker obviously this is a no op for
you second you need to enable Kayenta
and once again on spinnaker io
slash setup slash canary you'll find
detailed instructions for setup and
guides for how you can get kind of the
canary analysis set up on your spinnaker
instance in third
aside from directly spinnaker or kantha
related you need to ensure that your
applications and your infrastructure
metrics are being reported to your
metric store so that kinda can then act
on those so after the base set ups are
done on the top row on the bottom row is
about you starting on your journey that
chris mentioned of figuring out what are
the right metrics for your particular
situation and that iterative refining
and ongoing process of improving your
canary signals so number one identifying
the metrics that are strong indicators
of safety for your particular
application and infrastructure among the
set that you set up on the previous step
of infrastructure application metrics
being collected and then finally
configure your Canaries and once again
as Chris mentioned this is going to be
an iterative and continuing process for
you to go do so we're very proud of the
collaborative good work that we've done
here thanks for joining us we want to
continue ask you to continue invite you
to continue to join us by joining in on
the community on slack joined our
spinnaker i/o or you can go to reach us
with any questions or for help there's
plenty of documentation as I mentioned
on our main website spinnaker at i/o and
then of course we also welcome
contributors whether they are bug fixes
small features or large things as such
as adding an entire metric store our
project is open source and you can find
our code on github at slash spinnaker
slash canta so stay tuned for live QA
next we'll be back in under a minute
you
welcome back all right we're gonna do
some Q&A so these are questions from the
audience and I'll lead off with the
first question
is it possible to override the results
of the automated canary analysis what if
I need to deploy even if the system
thinks the canary failed yes so there
are a couple of answers to this yep so
it's pretty straightforward to override
the result spinnaker itself nothing
specific to ok inta supports the ability
to have both conditional stages and
branch operations and you can use
expressions in those conditions so you
can very easily do one thing if the the
analysis past one if it failed and join
those back up in a manual judgment so
that's fairly straightforward to
configure more importantly if if you're
if you're noticing that that folks are
overriding the decision of the canary
analysis often you might want to revisit
that actual configuration see if it
needs to be refined because it probably
is a signal that folks lack trust in the
canary analysis maybe it's wrong metrics
maybe it runs for two too short of a
period of time there could be some
reason why you need to actually address
the root cause and not just override the
decision and move on all right let's
think we can both do the next one so
I'll read the question what's next for
canta could you give some details on how
the automatic optimization process could
work and why we would want to do that
you want to lead off and then share so
comments as well so what's next for
Kanta
there's a few avenues that were
exploring for the future of cancer that
relates more to the analysis side of
things let Matt talk a little bit more
the infrastructure and the spinnaker
work after myself so some of the work
we're doing for Kanta and where we want
to expand and move towards is making our
results a little more practical so right
now we see a lot of sensitivity in our
approach and some of the metric
classifications or metric results we
give are not necessarily as practical as
our end users would like so we want to
spend some time to revisit kind of how
do we make our results a little more
practical for our end users to consume
the idea is to reduce risk we also want
to make these results practical and
something that you can use to gain
safety in your deployments in addition
as described through the demo and
throughout the presentation you know
kinda is very much a mini batch or micro
batch system where over some period of
time were performing little batches of
analysis over time we'd like to
investigate or move more towards a
continuous evaluation approach where
we're continually evaluating over an
entire period of time say every minute
generating a score this allows us
potentially to fail even faster so if
you look at a canary deployment we look
at the risk is the greatest in the you
know the first hour the first 30 minutes
of the first 15 minutes and so finding
those failures or those issues faster is
very critical to you know this system
managing that risk and so we want to
work at failing faster and finding those
big differences and those you know big
impactful changes sooner and this will
help mitigate the risk and be able to
roll your deployments back faster great
thanks okay
in terms of what's next for Kent I can
give some some information on what's X
for the project itself we've we've made
all this available works quite well
we're very happy with the current state
of things now we'd really like to focus
on adoption making it easy for folks to
get up and running we have quite a bit
of documentation but we'd like more
obviously we want to build out code labs
potentially a workshop and most
importantly we want to grow their
community we have support at the moment
for stackdriver
Atlas Prometheus and data dog the data
dog support was added by our Murray
we'd like to repeat that process have
other other like active participants in
the spinnaker community add support for
additional metric stores there's a
pretty well defined path for adding
support for additional metric stores we
have a like a development guide and we
have very easy to follow commits that
explain step by step how to add support
for new systems or add new integrations
and in addition we built Kantor from
scratch to be easy to develop with in so
everything is exposed there are
troubleshooting endpoints everything is
swaggered it's pretty well documented so
it's it's a pretty straightforward
process it's not trivial but it's
definitely doable and it's quite
straightforward I think what also is
next is you know more engagement from
the community and getting everyone else
involved in it contributing and also
expanding our documentation and our best
practices you know we want to be able to
bundle in best practices with cantos so
whether that includes example
configurations of metric
for example pipelines now that's also in
terms of getting feedback from you the
people out there wanting to use it and
iterating on that as well yeah we had
talked a couple times about maybe making
it smarter in terms of suggesting
optimizations to canary configurations
or even proposing canary configurations
when there was an issue that a human
responded to maybe the human could come
back and say for this release for this
the scope so this these time boundaries
with this resources
what sort of canary process would have
caught this would have sucked out that
there's a problem and said this is not a
safe deployment so we think we can get
smarter about that over time and really
not leave folks with blank screens where
they they have to figure out all this
configuration from scratch all right so
the next question is documentation
mentions real-time and retrospective
evaluation can you give some pointers
regarding which to use when all right
I'll lead off them jump in if you want
to add something so real-time we touched
on it a bit the ideas as part of a
release pipeline you provision the
resources and then you want to compare
the metrics being collected from those
resources you've just provisioned so you
would have typically a warmup period and
then for both the newly provisioned
baseline and production and canary
deployments you would compare those
metrics to one another real-time meaning
the metrics collected over the last hour
two hours three hours retrospective is
similar for all of the configuration
with the exception of the timing
information instead of saying start now
wait this period of time and then do
these intervals it says for these given
encoded timestamps do the analysis you
can still do it in intervals but it's it
refers to a passed points in time the
benefit of this besides being much
easier to demo is that you can
experiment with different configurations
so different judges different metrics
stores what precise less precise data
more metrics less metrics and so on all
right I think the next one's probably
yours so can you talk a little bit about
your experience with optimizing canary
analysis for applications
what were your top three lessons bits of
advice B it's a good question much like
the practical considerations is I think
one of the big lessons to take away is
that the metrics matter is the signals
you put into the system are going to be
very important to the success of canary
analysis the idea of garbage in garbage
out you give it bad metrics you
potentially get
bad results so there is this time this
iterative process of taking your canary
release and iterating on those metrics
and finding the right signals that are
going to be successful for doing a
canary analysis and kind of piggybacking
off that idea of your putting the right
metrics into the system is making sure
that your infrastructure is set up
correctly for example making sure that
that baseline and that canary are both
your running you know in the production
in the same region taking the same
amount of traffic the experimental setup
or the infrastructure setup is very
crucial to making canary analysis a
success and so having that combination
of a good setup and a good experiments
set up the right metrics really levy
it's a lot of the issues with you know
downstream canary analysis with why did
this fail or why did I see a difference
so focusing on kind of a set up and the
metrics can alleviate a lot of those
problems down the road yeah this is a
really great point if you can't absent
spinnaker in Atlanta clearly identify
how to segment like along what dimension
to segment the metrics that you've
collected you won't be able to perform
the analysis can't is it going to
magically discern the difference between
metrics you've collected you have to be
able to collect them identify the two
groups of metrics that you've collected
that you want to compare that's what the
judge considers when it's performing its
analysis that's that's a great point so
with that I think we're out of time
continue to look for answers to your
questions folks we'll be answering those
in the setup after the webinar ends
thanks everybody for your time stay
tuned for the next session build modern
apps using an API first strategy
you
you